what's up guys bangbang lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right we are trying to bring you
all of the news and the laughs in 20
minutes or less I've got the beautiful
and intelligent plan Tamara Nova here
with me how you doing
oh she's promoting the profile today
she's got this is if you don't pay to
have sponsorship on the show you can't
just be sponsoring stuff this is
unacceptable what's going on with three
trillion dollars oh man
House Democrats unveiled new three
trillion-dollar coronavirus relief bill
you called it a lunch money once they
start printing they're now gonna be able
to stop I don't even have the patience
to talk about this today so the last
stimulus bill was two trillion dollars
in that bill was all kinds of things
like an extra $600 a week for
unemployment benefits through the end of
July they had the 350 billion dollars
they were gonna give to small businesses
there was bailouts for pretty much
everybody they bailed out the airlines
they bill about the colleges and
universities
there's handing out money to everybody
two trillion dollars right is a lot of
money well they basically ran out of
that money pretty quickly
and now the Democrats have come forward
with a 1,800 page proposal it is 1,800
pages there's no way they've read this
whole thing so that's the first sham
second of all there's three trillion
dollars of garbage in here and the
reason why I say that is because they're
just printing money to just print money
right three trillion dollars are in the
proposal one third of that a trillion
dollars is gonna go to bailout state and
local governments this is out of a movie
this is but it's a cartoon movie it's a
comedy show the government's gonna
bailout the government by printing money
it's absurd then on top of that they're
going to expect extend the unemployment
benefits from the end of July those sets
$600 a week they're going to extend that
all the way till January 2021 as I said
previously once you give something to
people you can't take it away it would
be political suicide
for them to take it away you can't I
can't say no Polina I'm gonna give you a
hundred dollars every week 100 off or in
this case six hundred dollars every week
on top of your unemployment benefits and
now I'm gonna take it away from you
because people don't remember that that
it was so kind of you or so nice of you
to give it in the first place all they
remember that you took it away from them
later politicians aren't in that
business so on top of all of that
they've got money in there they've got I
think seventy five billion dollars for
testing and contact tracing they're
giving money to all sorts of businesses
what do you before I go off on a tangent
and complain about all this what do you
think I feel like you're a same voice in
all of us I mean I think it's important
to help people I just cannot believe
that we're printing trillions of got
like I don't even know what that means
do you want to know what the best stat
of all of this is when we started 2020
the feds the Federal Reserve's balance
sheets are thinking that as their bank
account had about four trillion dollars
in it all right
well right now so they've been growing
it by hundreds of billions of dollars a
week it's now over six trillion so they
had fit more than 50% growth if this
goes through as I predicted at the end
of March they will have doubled their
balance sheet in the first six months of
this year if they literally have gone
from four to over a trillion dollars I
don't know what the magnitude of this
means but I feel like it's not gonna be
great
here's the problem I wrote about this
today and this is the this is the real
talk this is serious I don't remember
something about quantitative easing is a
drug and we're addicted the problem is
that quantitative easing gives the
Mirage of short-term help people right
now are saying oh my god thank you so
much so the government I appreciate this
unemployment benefit I appreciate you
bailing out my business I appreciate the
PPP loan that allows me to keep my
employees online right it feels good
that's the high of a drug right we're
all feeling great the stock market's
rallying people are saying yes we're
recovering it's all a mirage because the
economic data underlying all this is
getting worse and worse that's a roading
away and what ends up happening is
quantitative easing just like a drug it
- hi in the short term but over the long
term it ravages and kills your body and
that's what happens to a society and so
what we're literally seeing is they're
printing trillions of dollars and
they're devaluing the currency in the
short term you get this massive effect
where you can stabilize and have markets
recover but over a long period of time
that currency devaluation means that 45%
of Americans who can't afford an
emergency pip payment or don't own any
stocks they are going to see their
wealth stolen from them they're going to
wake up every day and that cash that
they have that they live paycheck to
paycheck in their bank account buys them
less goods this is exactly what brings
down every single giant estate do you
know what this reminds me of what when
you have like a start-up and all these
investors are giving it millions and
billions in some cases of dollars yet
they don't know that the underlying
technology doesn't work and then it all
comes crumbling down of course but look
here's here's the thing we actually can
reverse course right like they don't
have to do this here's what you want to
know what the solution is right there's
three things that they should do it's
pretty simple one open the economy get
people back to work safely how do we do
it safely tell people if you're old sick
or have a pre-existing condition stay at
home if you're not one of those three
categories get back to work we're gonna
take away the masks wear masks wash your
hands social distancing we're going to
take away the unemployment benefits
because there's actually a lot of people
right now that are making more money on
unemployment than they were at their
jobs now I'm of the belief that's not
the individual employees fault that says
more about what we pay our employees
before the pandemic than it does about
the unemployment of it take away that
incentive get people back to work sort
driving that economic activity that
velocity of money again that's step one
step two then is start to bring back all
of those jobs from overseas we've seen
that the you know Tomas said this on the
podcast where we we pursued an efficient
society
we looked for the lowest cost goods the
most efficient supply chains etc so he
went outside the United States but what
it did was it made us less resilient
right we lost all of the concrete kind
of bulletproof nosov the American
economy because now we're dependent on
these other countries so bring all of
that back start generating tons and tons
of economics
here and the third thing is get the
government out of the way the most
comical part of this entire thing to me
is if you asked anyone who is the worst
capital allocator in the world it's the
government I don't care what country the
government is the worst Kapoor allocator
and so instead in this three trillion
dollar proposed package we are literally
gonna take a trillion dollars from we're
in a handed the state local governments
that are notorious for being horrendous
capital allocators we're literally
lighting money on fire like that it's
all a joke it's a sham they literally
are just gonna print and print and print
and print why are they gonna do it
politicians average age in today society
they are older than they've ever been
they won't be around to pay that pay the
bill if I go into a buffet with a bunch
of friends eating all of the food and
then saying you know what I got to go to
the bathroom and Irish exiting literally
just leaving and leaving the bill to
somebody else that's what they're doing
but if you're watching this and you're
under the age of 30 or under the age of
40 you're gonna pay the bill because
your savings is gonna be eroded you're
the one who's gonna have to pay high
prices for goods you're the one who's
got to deal with the inflation not them
not the person who's 60 70 80 years old
exactly all right let's move on to JC
Penney
that's my tirade for the day before I
forget if you agree or disagree I would
love to hear what people think so leave
a comment and tell me what you think and
I'll read through all the comments and
see what people think we serve as a way
to run a poll
all right go JC Penney no we don't need
your polling anything so JC Penney is
has an impending Friday bankruptcy
filing and it's in talks for 450 million
dollar loan when's the last time you
shot the JC Penney JC Penney 12 so
here's what I would say to all of the
all of the Socialists right here's one
of the shams in society there's more
socialists on Wall Street than
capitalists so what I would say to the
Socialists on Wall Street is why aren't
you guys begging for the government to
bail out JC Penney oh it's because the
capital markets work JC Penney is
running out of money they're gonna file
bankruptcy or I think they might have
already filed for it they're planning
okay so they haven't filed yet but all
of a sudden there might be a midnight
hour deal where the cap
markets come in and equity or debt
provider gives them capital to avoid
bankruptcy that's how markets work
pennies one of those stores that should
have shut its doors a long time ago I'm
actually shocked that they're still
around why do you think they should have
shut their doors as a foot traffic was
in their ecommerce they couldn't really
compete its JCPenney should have learned
the lesson from Domino's in Starbucks
three to five years ago and realized if
we can pivot our business and take it
from a retail learn person physical
store and try to get it online right did
they think they are online it's just
nobody shopping no one shopping there
because there's like an old brand it's
like JC Penney is the type of place that
your grandmother says ok I'm gonna I'm
gonna bring you to the mall let's go to
JC Penney and I'll buy you something
right how is it nod McDonald's is poppin
you ever walked in and now I have the
the kiosk they're hip with the times
baby let's go yeah we'll see what
happens with that but the other thing
that I would say too is I feel like JC
Penney if they do file for bankruptcy
are they gonna happen like 80 percent
off sale where I can go buy like
sweatpants and jeans and stuff we one
time we're walking around near Central
Park and there is this like really rich
you caught he calls in rich stores this
is stored and for rich people and we
walked past it and it's it like we're
shutting down everything must go we
walked in even though everything was 80
percent off it was still like three
thousand dollars you were like yeah well
my whole thing is the reason why I call
them rich stores is because when I walk
in literally they like start whispering
into their microphones and stuff they're
like calling security
one time pull in and I went to what is a
place called yeah that place a friend of
ours opened a bar he's part of a team
that opened a bar inside of it in New
York City right by Central Park and so
we went to just go see what it looked
like but we went in and literally had on
sweatpants sweatshirt you know we just
finished yeah and so as we walked
through the store literally people were
looking at us like they don't belong
here I was just like alright
speaking of uber and GrubHub what's
going on there there's rumors that uber
is eyeing GrubHub for an acquisition
smart or not smart
I think smart why because uber you know
everybody knows that whoo girl eats is
like the the meat of the business so I
think if they double down on that
that'll be really smart for them
so basically ridership of ubers
obviously falling off a cliff because
the coronavirus but even before that it
was still growing it just wasn't kind of
the explosive growth they saw in the
early days Boober eats however the food
delivery service that had been the
fastest growing segment I think it made
up about twenty percent of all of their
revenue before the pandemic and so what
are you gonna do like why not go buy the
company that is your biggest competitor
probably and then just start to
incorporate them and expand your empire
but isn't it kind of counterintuitive
because wouldn't GrubHub be doing really
well right now GrubHub probably is doing
right yeah but but the whole point is it
doesn't matter if the other company's
doing well or not if you're Ober and you
have kind of global domination as your
thought process then the best thing that
you can do is go just buy the competitor
is it interesting to you that it would
be an all-stock deal I mean if you're a
grub hub that's probably attractive
right now cuz I'm guessing that uber
stock is down pretty significantly uh
grub hub stock has probably been maybe
flat is my guess I actually don't know
what's happened but I doubt that they've
actually been crushed as bad as other
stocks because people know that people
are ordering food and so if you're a
grub hub and you take all stock and
you're basically betting on the fact
that stock markets gonna recover over
the next three to five years it actually
made it turn out to be a pretty good
financial transaction interesting would
you buy goober stock right now are you
long I know but like if you if you had
to make a choice would you buy Luber
stock or now you would why like you said
I think it all as the economy recovers
probably recover people are always gonna
need to go places and eat food all right
that's fair what's going on Facebook
Facebook PTSD what is this okay so
Facebook is gonna pay fifty two million
dollars to content moderators who've
suffered from PTSD because if you're a
content
writer you are likely to develop some
like mental health issues on the job as
you're looking at these things that you
have to take down the website and
they're mostly graphic so basically the
way moderation works is people can flag
or the algorithm Flags like sensitive
content so this could be everything from
sex crimes child trafficking murder you
know physical violence terrorism related
content all that kind of stuff and so if
your job is just to sit there all day
and just look at this stuff like you're
literally just you know literally being
just bombarded all day long with these
graphic images I buy it that there's
definitely some psychological effect to
it I'm not shocked that somebody went
and probably sued Facebook over it
in terms of some lawyer saw an
opportunity to do that at the same time
you know there's an argument that the
workers knew that they were gonna do
content moderation and they took the job
yes but if you look at there's a really
great profile on this if you look at you
know who the workers are a lot of times
as people who need the money who maybe
wouldn't pick that type of job normally
but you know it allows them to don't
disagree yeah IIIi think that this is a
good thing for Facebook to do right and
I do agree that these people probably
have had the mental anguish and
suffering but at the same time there's
an element of me that says like if you
don't like the job then there should be
things that like Facebook should help
people find another job if they don't
like this job within Facebook right but
again it's super complex so at least are
gonna get some money to kind of
compensate this in my thing is like I
don't care how much money you give me is
that gonna cure my drinking problem my
depression my you know anxiety probably
not know but there's probably nothing
else that they can do right all right
speaking of solving problems work from
home for ever
you sure wrote for like the number four
and then evey a full ever we don't what
so Twitter has told its employees they
can work from home for you surprised no
I mean look working from home I think a
lot of people
had heard of it before remote work all
these things but they were like oh I
could never do that now they've been
forced to do it and I think a lot of
people are realizing like oh this isn't
nearly as bad as I thought it was gonna
actually may enjoy it so I don't think
that everybody's painting work from home
to be this new like shocking thing this
has been around forever and I think
companies like Twitter I'm sure had
great flexible work from home policies
when I was at Facebook what we used to
do is we used to do no beeping
Wednesday's because a lot of engineers
basically would work from home on
Wednesday and it was kind of like an
unspoken rule type thing where you tried
to have no set in-person meetings on a
Wednesday it does not surprise me that
technology companies are leading the way
saying like look we can do this from
anywhere if you look in like the crypto
space take a company like finance
they've got hundreds of employees 500
plus employees in 40 different countries
then they don't have offices Wow
so completely decentralized huh yeah but
but like what what is the difference
between going in person and doing it on
Zoom I mean there's not much but I just
think being in person just adds an
element of you can read a situation
better you can you know you're more I
don't know I don't disagree that there's
advantages to going in person but do the
advantages outweigh the disadvantages
right so the disadvantages of having to
commute having to have office space
having to potentially now there's a
health concern I will say if you live
with another person if you have kids
like it's just very disruptive to do
work with all these different
distractions and having to listen to
your meetings and interviews I have to
go in the other it's just it's a it's
art but then that brings the question of
it's because we live in our apartment in
New York City if people know that they
can work from home they don't have to
live in a big city will they now spread
out throughout the country and say hey
you know what rather than pay an absurd
amount of money for an apartment in New
York why don't we go buy a house
somewhere where that has that has
multiple rooms and then it's not so much
like we're cramped together you can go
in your office I can go in my office my
office would be the garage I would go
just hide out and watch TV or something
wait so I was actually wondering before
you said that I was like why do you
think it's important for these companies
to say
you can work from home forever like why
is it important for them to say that
clearly we won't be returning to an
office soon
but I think it is that it's if you want
to relocate you will you have the option
because you will be able to work from
home forever yes so first of all there's
like a status review good thing like
Twitter's a little bit different I think
but like Facebook Google and they're all
like posturing like someone's like hey
you can work from home till August
because he's like hey you work from home
until September so October it so it's
like becomes this like weird like
contest right of who's cooler or who's
more woke I think what Twitter is
basically saying though is like look
we'll have an office you can go to the
office you want or you can work from
home forever like we're changing the
policy of the way that we do work and it
does give people now the freedom to say
how do I want to design my life and
optimize for happiness and productivity
rather than I haven't going deal yes for
example um one time we took a trip to
Italy and we worked remotely from there
and we had the advantage of being five
hours ahead of us time so we could get a
lot done before people in the US were
even awake so for somebody who has - who
is doing a job they can do from a
computer like I think this is great
would you move to Europe no I like
America like America what about Puerto
Rico oh my god you inferno Rico I just
figure this conversation offline I just
think it's funny to keep giving her [ __ ]
that we should leave to Puerto Rico
Mexico yeah I like this
they got good talk what do you think
that offices will severely downsize
because of this so I wrote about this
yesterday three potential three
potential outcomes one is people get rid
of their office - is people change the
layout of their office or three is Eric
Schmidt seems I think people are gonna
rent more office spaces more distance in
between people I disagree with Eric
Schmidt I do not think we were going to
get more office space I think that
there's gonna be a combination of the
second to some types of businesses will
completely get rid of their offices
other types of businesses will keep the
same amount of space but they'll change
the way that it works so kind of an open
floor plan will go away etc all right
we're almost out of our time
what's going on early humans okay this
is so cool
yesterday so human bones from a
Bulgarian cave suggest that our species
arrived in Europe thousands of years
earlier than previously thought
sharing the continent much longer with
Neanderthals so they think that people
were in Bulgaria that part of the world
faster yeah yeah have you ever read Guns
Germs and Steel yes yeah I think it's
pretty good it's really good what do you
what do you think the early humans
thought when they were walking around
and there wasn't much going on like you
know like they were walking around like
there's no buildings and stuff right
basically they were out in the
wilderness on their room they had to
survive based on what they could do
hunting and gathering my friends like
easier times I guess they weren't
worried about working from home but how
humans could have potentially been in
Bulgaria because I'm the only difference
I don't think that's what the article
says that's not what the article says my
brain is that's not what the article
says the article says that humans got to
Europe earlier than previously thought
not that that's the earliest humans the
earliest humans definitely rely on
Europe you're biased took over there by
the way I just want you guys to know
that she literally is reading an article
from the New York Post and on the side
hold on and on the side there is a link
to another article that says ancient
squid attack revealed in two hundred
million year old fossil why didn't you
choose to talk about their early humans
and not the ancient squid attack because
I wanted to tell you that I'm more
advanced than you because I'm from
Bulgaria what are you talking
because they're bones in a cave people
were in Italy before Europe no literally
the country of Bulgaria is only there
because Italians came guys we went to
Italy and he kept telling people that he
was Italian and they would start
speaking him in Italian and I was like
no no not that type of Italian like
Italian American or as an American
Italian yeah these Italian burger
alright guys that's it for today lunch
money well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right we are trying to
keep these two 20 minutes we've been
screwing that up over the last couple
days so we will try to get back to 20
minutes or less
and we will see you guys tomorrow shout
out to all my homeless a peon